[Music]
in Silicon Valley there's the fail fast
fail forward
the fetishizing of failure and it's
become very trendy I think it's
extremely misleading and misinterpreted
and misaligned in many cases so whether
you ask say Peter Thiel who views
failure as always being a tragedy
there is no exception and it is not some
aesthetic imperative or learning
imperative necessarily where you talk to
say Marc Andreessen for instance who I
interviewed for to paraschiv and also
for tools of titans and he says when I
was getting started I'm paraphrasing
here my goodness when I was getting
started we didn't have a fancy word for
it we just called it a fuckup we didn't
call it a pivot I think that it would be
better to say iterate fast and iterate
forward so there's no problem with
getting say feedback on a minimally
viable product or an early version of a
product - Reid Hoffman another person
I've interviewed a founder / cofounders
of LinkedIn and the Oracle of Silicon
Valley is he's referred to even by a lot
of the elite investors for instance in
Silicon Valley believes that you should
effectively if you're not embarrassed by
the first version of your product that
you ship you're too late and that's true
I think in software development and
different types of user interfaces and
so on but it's not always true for say a
book or other types of creative
endeavors so it's it's a case of being
very specific in what you mean by
failure and also making sure that what
you're transplanting from one area to
another if you are doing that actually
applies in your industry in your trade
in your craft but I certainly feel like
doing your homework coming out and maybe
the Silicon Valley ethos should start
looking to the military more to say
I think it's david hackworth I think I'm
getting that right who said if you find
yourself in a fair fight you didn't
prepare properly or something along
those lines
I mean it is entirely
plausible and possible to come out and
just smash your competition from second
one around one and I think that even if
you do end up failing and then
correcting course that's a good
aspiration to have not to come out
really shoddy and handicapped from the
get-go expecting to pivot twenty seven
times then if you look at my portfolio
for instance I have about 70 companies
I've invested in I was a pre-seed
advisor to uber and ubers business model
hasn't really changed it's been the same
for a very long time if you look at
Derek Siver's the founder of CD Baby he
came up with the business model in about
five minutes of going to a used record
store and asking them how they did it
and it remained the same effectively for
ten years fifteen years until he sold it
for whatever was twenty four million
dollars so you don't have to fail so
that prerequisite for having a
successful company or a successful life
you just have to learn so I think
learning and iterating are two words
that are going to be more valuable than
failure but when failure does slap you
in the face when fortune serves you out
the tidal wave of some type or quicksand
being able to adapt to that and not
emotionally overreact I think is
certainly important but you shouldn't
strive for failure if you look across
all of the icons Titans world-class
performers that I've interviewed in the
say wealthy section write for if we're
dividing them into healthy wealthy and
wise we look at the business side of
things one of the most common patterns
that you spot is absurd questions and
the power of the absurd question is
really something that I've paid a lot of
attention to in the last few years
whether that say Peter Thiel so serial
billionaire certainly an incredible
entrepreneur but also an incredible
investor good at betting on presidents
turns out as well and he would ask
questions such as why can't you
accomplish your ten-year plan in the
next six months and they took say Peter
Diamandis chairman of the XPrize he
might ask the founders of companies he's
looking at as potential investments if
you had to 10x the economics of your
startup
in the next film in the period of time
six months three months how would you do
it and if they say it can't be done
that's not something we can do it's
impossible his responses I don't accept
that answer
try again those types of questions I
think are whether it's 10x thinking
hundred X however you frame that it
could also be a constraint for instance
if you had to accomplish all of your
work or grow your company to X while
working two hours a week if you had a
gun against your head
how would you attempt to do that these
type of absurd questions don't allow you
to use your default frameworks for
solutions they don't allow you to use
your base of current assumptions to come
up with answers it forces you to think
laterally it forces you to break some of
the boundaries on the sphere of comfort
that you've created for yourself and
that is what makes them I think in a way
so powerful and these are not questions
by the way I think are valuable if you
ponder them for 10 seconds and go hmm
yeah maybe I would do this and then move
on with your day I think that journaling
as an adjunct to asking these questions
is is very very important so I will sit
down very often in the morning one of my
rituals also borrowing from a lot of
these people's morning journaling of
some type and I tend to use either
morning pages five miniature or just a
separate type of free hand sort of goal
dissection and this would be a case
where I would ask one of those questions
and I would write freehand for say three
pages three to five pages and drink some
tea as I'm doing it and that is when you
will not only come up with interesting
ideas and there might be 90% garbage but
if you have 10% that leads you in an
interesting direction that could
completely revolutionize your business
or your life if you take that seed and
do something with it and that's been the
case for me for a very long time I
actually created a list at one point
after observing this pattern among these
people I was interviewing and I just
made a list of what are the most absurd
things I could do right now really into
my life
and business I created this long list
and some of them were terrible I mean
literally I was at a conference us board
and that's as I was doing this and some
of them were very specific doesn't
really one of them was cut off my own
feet I mean like what the hell and so I
just regarded that one I still have my
feet you can't see it but they're intact
and at the same time though one of them
was take a complete break from startup
investing so retire from startup
indefinite because that had become a
source of stress due to the inbound to
the deal flow and that was a real
game-changer for me taking my indefinite
startup vacation about two years ago
which has led to incredible growth in
other areas including in my own
businesses so there you have it the
power of absurd questions
[Music]